Kyrie gets in the paint the floater for
two
I'll start gaem why that was speaking
Boston idea height is two more for Kyrie
Tyrese is that's good control rates
going full speed to the basket to the
leaf
you and he were good friends till you
skipped his wedding how he is so bad I
read knocks it down and we'll get to the
line
good screen by Al Horford yeah I mean
Rick Carlisle does have Irene at these
three
what a read by kairi kairi
g14 three are pushed by Kyrie Latian
against a guy who gonna be bigger like
Al Horford
the rain gets picked off and three
drills the jump shot forget about the
best backward into easy hesitation
throws it out for smart gets it back in
the corner takes it makes it far this
team
Kyrie got a three out of second three to
me that's a three 8:47 final minute here
opening half Irving eight for eight now
in the game incredible back down by
Horford
Kyrie pull-up three
[Applause]
Irene loops it inside the brown gets it
easy too
good recognition by Kyrie with the
mismatch at home loose ball
Tyrese got it gets to the head Jason to
the basket to Kyrie hated run on the
floor makes the catch and the same smart
with the hustle play saves it again
Kyrie three three with the miss Irving
the other way it keeps going with the
dribble keeps it alive spins back thanks
at home by far again they go to Dirk
Dirk spins in the lane lost the ball on
the pack comes Tyreke Watson's got
numbers on the break throwing it up
Hayden Cyrene's will stop her go who
began
I came at 100 Tyrese Trin's takes it in
the paint back at his way down off the
finger roll
[Applause]